hi there steve here again i guess we're
for sure
three weeks at least into my 90-day
challenge
uh yesterday i talked about some of the
frustrations uh that sense that i can't
understand the korean as well as i would
like um
that you know it's that long long road
where you've now
can actually say some things in the
language understand things but yet
you're not really able to understand the
content that you're interested in at
least when listening and then you know i
thought to myself i said
hold it a minute here
here i am korean i've gone at it three
times
three separate occasions at least you
know an hour a day or so
here in vancouver
um
now when i think back to when i lived in
japan i lived in japan for nine years
how long did it take before i could
understand political discussion on the
radio a long time i think it took
a few years a few years living in japan
so
actually i'm doing better than i did
when i was in japan i was speaking more
in japan but the goal right now that i
want to get to is to to where i can
understand these political podcasts
because if i can understand them i know
from experience that's just going to
wash over my brain and eventually
uh get me to where i can speak better
so
hey i'm doing better you know and if i
look at my if i look at my statistics uh
here at link you know uh like i have
like 37 000 known words in korean i
don't know what my my account would be
in japanese because i've never learned
japanese at link so i don't have a word
counted link it's going to be higher but
maybe not that much higher but higher
yeah maybe quite a bit higher you know i
just don't know but
in the last month here or because our
statistics that link go sort of day week
month so
last month
um
i have
uh
read
blah blah blah blah blah 31 780 words
like 32 000 words i have read in a three
week period
i wasn't able to do that in japanese
because all i had was these either i had
these rather uninteresting books with
word lists where i was constantly
flipping back and forth or i had to try
and read the newspaper with with the
dictionary which was hopeless
you know and uh in the last three weeks
i have
saved
3548 links that is i have looked up
3500 words 3500 words that are in my
database now that pop up again as as
yellow words
uh i have increased my known words total
by 3 300 words in three weeks
there's no way that i was doing that in
japanese so
uh i have tools available to me now for
example i can go and access this podcast
uh
kim jong bae's podcast every day
there's more than i can possibly handle
complete with transcripts audio that i
can import and link i can work on and
i'm learning about
uh you know
the secretary general of the united
nations uh pangamoon might be going back
to korea to run in the presidential
elections all this kind of stuff is very
interesting and they have two people
debating one on the right's wing and one
on the left wing and stuff so i'm
following all this stuff
but of course again i'm in the car going
to play hockey this morning i'm
listening i can't really understand what
they're talking about then i get back
here and i work my way through it and of
course now i understand it much better
and i'm going to go listen again so all
i wanted to say with all of this ramble
is
yeah it's frustrating that i can't
understand but we have to have realistic
expectations and if i consider how long
it took me and i was working hard in
japan at my language i was doing a lot
of listening and reading and had this
naga naganuma reader all in hiragana
which i would read boring as hell such
fairy stories from japan and stuff like
that
and then i'd find other readers i mean i
was listening to this show
which was a wonderful
nhk tape of the history of the showa era
with the actual speeches of the people
starting from 1925 up until up until the
end of the war or no up until macarthur
up until you know until the shoah
emperor
ceased to be the emperor i can't
remember actually to be honest
what he did he abdicated or he died i
shouldn't know
um
but i listen to this stuff over and over
and over again no transcripts no chance
of really getting a hang on you know the
handle on what they're saying kind of
more or less listening to it so
one should be happy with what one has
achieved one should not have unrealistic
expectations
and uh you know you i gotta remind
myself here i am i'm actually reading
stuff in korean and i i i know that in
another month or two i'm going to be
able to understand the podcast so don't
be too hard on yourself
and that's what i have to say thank you
for listening now i gotta go cook dinner
i won't go into details of what i plan
to cook for dinner unless people are
interested and then i'll talk about it
next time bye for now